George Clooney and his wife Hazama Homme
doll Amal scuse me are speaking out sir
what's her name John yeah
my name is Amal Clooney I know we think
Johnson gonna take two what yes
um all are speaking out for the first
time about bringing in Iraqi refugee 2
in the United States the couple teamed
up with Clooney's parents to sponsor
Hazem Abdal the Clooney's introduced him
to David Letterman in a wide-ranging
interview for his new Netflix series
[Music]
this morning apparently we're faced I
mean our family with 50 cameramen or so
in the kitchen which is George you and
I'm olive heard this story before I'm
hearing it from him for the first time
and can you imagine a number of your CDs
who've been the victims of genocide
perpetrated by Isis over the last couple
of years that's how I met has him and
when I met him I remember being so
struck by his courage but also just this
amazing spirit and how he spoke about
even after everything he'd lost he spoke
about our desire for justice not revenge
and he talked about the future and what
his dreams were and I remember him
telling us we were all in New York I was
with George and Nick and Nina and he
spoke about his dream of one day
studying in the US and I know we all had
the same thought which was well maybe
there's something we can do to help with
that
that's him all talking about of doll to
get that straight
Javed all came to the US last year he's
a student at the University of Chicago
and lives near Clooney's parents in
Kentucky Clooney also talks with
Letterman about his growing family your
wife must have known of your activity
and your humanitarian work and again
what a perfect match she is sort of this
remarkable human being and now mother
which is something I suppose I should
assume she would
be wonderful add as well but when you
see it in person it makes you feel you
know incredibly proud and also
incredibly small twins twins flynn's and
sounds fun doesn't it then you have a
pair and as they grow together you'll
take care of one another that's the hope
and you can have hobbies again
yeah in 20 years when I'm when I'm your
age the new episode of my next guest
needs no introduction with David
Letterman begins streaming on Netflix
tomorrow